just two miles from the scene of
yesterday's multiple stabbing attack
armed police surrounded the suspects
home in this block of flies the 25 year
old understood to be a Libyan national
resident to the UK was arrested earlier
near the scene
the man's neighbors were moved to safety
as officers conducted a detailed search
at one point the sound of an explosion
rang out the earlier attack in for berry
Gardens and Reddington centre was sudden
and violent police and members of the
public fought to save the lives of those
who'd been starved as here ambulances
paramedics and doctors arrived on scene
and began triaging multiple victims last
night around 7 o'clock I heard multiple
sirens we then heard an air ambulance
close over heads to where I live which
is about five minutes away from the park
and the air ambulance landed in a park
next to where we live called Kings
meadow we went to investigate and about
10 minutes later a further air ambulance
arrived and landed in the park and
paramedics from both of those air
ambulances made their way to the scene
police confirmed later that three people
had died three others are being treated
in hospital for serious injuries police
say they are keeping an open mind as to
the motive for the attack and although
they are not currently treating it as a
terrorist incident they are being
assisted by colleagues from the
southeast counterterrorism unit both the
Prime Minister and Home Secretary
expressed their shock at the events in
reading and said their thoughts were
with the victims their families and
first responders take some time to pause
and reflect remember those who have lost
their long think of those that were
critically injured and to remember that
we are talking about a senseless and act
here but it's important that we as the
community as we always do as a community
pull together police issued a statement
to confirm the attack was not linked to
a black lives matter protest which
happened in the same park but ended
three hours before the stabbings the
main suspect remains in police custody
this morning Thames Valley Police say
they have no intelligence to suggest
that there is any further danger to the
public however there are geing people to
remain vigilant and report anything
suspicious to the police